how did you say no to all of those
temptations every time people said you
got to get on a social media platform
you know facebook was the first and the
way i
remember it it was the spring of 2004
right i was a college senior in the
spring of 2004. back then facebook was
going
university to the university it was
still sort of in a beta stage so it came
to
it came to where i was i was at
dartmouth college i remember my friends
and my girlfriend everyone was sort of
into it right like ah it's the
facebook.com it's sort of like
the literal facebooks we have but but
virtual and there was like an
arbitrary reason why i didn't sign up
and my memory of the arbitrary reason
was
i don't like listing favorites it's a
weird
kick i have if you tell me what's your
favorite book what's your favorite movie
for whatever reason i i just can't do
that i have an aversion to it and early
facebook
this is what the profiles were centered
on as you would list your favorite
quotes you would list your favorite
movies so for an arbitrary reason
it's like oh i don't want to do that wow
that
accident though it gave me this
interesting almost anthropological
separation you know like i was margaret
mead
studying studying a tribes on an island
or something so i was separated from
social media as it began to spread
and after a while just observing it from
the outside to me became way more
interesting than actually being in it so
it was an
accident that got me started down this
path so okay fine so you decide not to
get on
your favorite and that was kind of like
your or your thing
but i mean from 04 to 2021 there's been
17 years for
7 billion something people in the world
to convince you to get on social
media and you still haven't done it so
what
there has to be other reasons why you
kept saying no no no to social media
what was that what was that reason
well so after i graduated college in
2004
i went to mit and i was not only the
computer science department but i was in
the theory group
within the computer science department
so this is the group in which you have
all the theoretical computer scientists
so we
literally stare at white boards and try
to solve math proofs
in this really unusual sort of
idiosyncratic type of professional
environment
focus was everything your ability to to
maintain
focus was really highly prized people
did not spend much time
engaging with the outside world it
wasn't reading a lot of news it was
i'm locked in trying to solve proof so i
went from college into this environment
where what people really cared about is
how hard can you focus and when i was in
that setting
to expose myself to tools that seem like
they are engineered to really distract
you
because even early on this was clear
that social media made money off your
attention
it's being engineered to get as much
attention as possible we all looked at
it with great suspicion so i didn't sign
up for arbitrary reasons and then once i
was in this unusual professional
environment
it became really suspicious of why would
i bring one of these tools into my life
it seems like it's going to get in the
way of what i'm doing it would be like a
professional athlete looking at
cigarettes and saying you know
i don't really want to bring these into
my life because i make a living off my
lung capacity do you have a tv do you
have tv in your house
yeah we have we have tvs my wife and i
are cinephiles we like to watch movies
so we have that
so uh wouldn't you see tv as a
distraction
and as cigarettes uh similar to what
social media would be
well so the issue i had with social
media was twofold
one no one really had a good reason
why i should be signing up for it that
definitely caught my attention it was
like because it's here
and i'm like okay but what do you do on
the facebook.com like well you know you
see
like who your roommates boyfriends are
dating or something but that's not
interesting
why should i sign up for this no one was
really giving me a good reason
whereas if you look at a tv and say
there's a great movie
and you can watch it on this screen i'll
say well that's a pretty compelling
reason
and two it became clear pretty early on
that these platforms had a lot of energy
being invested into making them as
sticky as an experience as possible
they have the ability to manipulate your
attention to manipulate your emotional
centers to manipulate your social
centers they get you to look at these
things
much longer than you knew was useful or
much longer than you knew was healthy in
a way that you couldn't really replicate
with something that was as asymmetric
and static as television so it was
really starting to get
concerned when i saw people with these
networks following them everywhere they
went
and was constantly pulling their
attention down to that phone right so
there seemed to be something new going
on so we had these platforms where no
one could really explain why i needed to
be on it
and yet it also seemed to be capturing
so much of people's time and attention
that for someone who made a living with
my brain i was very very wary about this
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview
and please don't forget to subscribe to
the channel take care everybody bye